Another question come in. I do want to address because somebody asked this question in the office today that they're getting the generator dull error. So they're getting that error message that it can't communicate with the generator.
So they're trying to run a program that won't communicate with the generator.
Now even in version 6.4 which to rife has boasted that you'll get less and less of that now with the new 6.4 program.
We've had people have that same problem even with the 6.4. The reason why sometimes when you turn on your rife and it says can't communicate with the generator, do you have your generator plugged in.
You have to go through the troubleshooting. Well did it get unplugged? Did the USB cable come out from the port in the computer? Did it come out from the back of the rife machine? Those are your first thing that you look at.
If no, that's all working. It will give you that error can communicate with the generator. If your rife isn't turned on. So if your machine itself is turned off, then it doesn't read that there's any generator there. So it's going to give you that generator dull error there.
But people have troubleshooting. No, it's all plugged in. It's all turned on. Everything's that's not the issue.
When you're running your rife machine, this is why we typically recommend when you hit run on your rife machine to close your computer.
When you close your computer, you're putting your computer to sleep because as soon as you hit run on the computer, it sends the program to the generator.
It sends the program to the F170 or F122. You don't need the computer anymore once you hit run. You could unplug the computer and you could burger to the other room. It will still run the program. The program has been sent to the generator to run.
I know I know a lot of people like to look at the program on the computer and look at the frequency that's running and look at the countdown of the time and all that kind of stuff.
Don't do that. And the reason why I say don't do that is when you have the computer open, you are actually exposing yourself to EFFs because every computer produces, you know, EFFs. You don't need that.
Secondly, you are exposing the computer to the frequencies from the rife machine.
You don't think these frequencies are strong. They are strong and they can they can feed back to the computer and they can kind of mess up the program a little bit.
And so with the countdown, sometimes people have said the timer is going up. It's not going down. What the what the blazes is that? Well, it's because the frequencies are just kind of messing with it. It's still run the program, but it can mess with the frequencies.
If you have a tendency to leave your computer open and run your program, it can throw off the communication from the computer to the generator.
Not this time. Let's say it's running and it, but next time the computer next time you hit try to run a program, it doesn't read the generator because you threw off that connection.
So the solution to that is to number one, just keep close your computer when you run a program, so you don't have that because it puts the computer to sleep and the computer is now, you know, not being affected by the frequencies.
But if that does happen, then, you know, just shut everything down, turn your computer down, reboot it and it should be just fun.
Worst case scenario, you can lose the driver, but that doesn't happen that often. You'd have to download the driver from the website, and we'd have to show you how to do that.
Matter of fact, we do have instructions on, I don't know if we do. I think we do have some instructions on the member site to do that, but that should not be a problem.
It should not be something you have to do.